foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar enabling
High throughput biology with new
technologies for synthetic construct
sequencing I am Kaylee Bach of lab roots
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by SQL
to learn more about our sponsor please
visit sequel.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd now like to welcome our speakers Joe
Miller co-founder and chief scientific
officer at SQL
Henry Chan synthetic biology lead at
octant
and Brian Young research associate in
synthetic biology technology at Ogden
Joe Henry Brian welcome you may now
begin your presentation
thank you very much for that
introduction
and welcome everybody to today's webinar
uh you'll hear today about how to enable
High throughput biology with new
technologies for synthetic construct
sequencing which is a application
webinar based on sequel's new Express
Plex technology
tell you a little bit about SQL we
really focus on how to solve some of the
crucial bottlenecks in NGS workflows our
goal is to help people sequence more
samples on sequencing instruments more
easily and we do so with workflows and
products that are designed to provide
enhanced multiplexing allowing you to
take samples and prepare them into NGS
libraries and get them onto sequencers
more quickly more easily with higher
performance
a crucial technology that we use to
build almost all of our products is an
enzyme called the tn5 transpose Ace
which is an incredibly versatile tool
for scaling and simplifying NGS
workflows
we have found tn5 to be an incredibly
powerful platform for creating Library
chemistry with a number of unique
advantages
for example being able to normalize and
create multiplexing with purpose-built
reagents
these reagents really form the core
capabilities that our products are based
on and we also have a lot of experience
in creating products that support
specific applications for example like
plasmid sequencing which you'll hear
about today
we think of these products as really the
product of a workflow engineering
approach that we have created that
builds on the core reagents themselves
and then creates streamlined products
that deliver cutting-edge integrated
workflow
many of these workflows are built into
other products that SQL has offered and
continues to offer starting with our
Plex well product
and most recently culminating with our
Pure Plex product launched last year and
expressplex which you'll hear about
today
all of these products really form the
basis of a series of different
technologies that support a range of
different multiplexing needs across
different applications such as
genotyping rna-seq
genome sequencing and plasmid and
amplicon sequencing
expressplex with is a very exciting new
product that we're launching this year
which you're going to hear about in
today's webinar and this product is
really
the culmination of
work on the part of our R D team to
create the fastest most highly
automatable Library prep possible
think of expressplex as being the
simplest possible way of turning DNA
into a sequencer ready Library
the way this works is we create plate
based products that allow you to put the
DNA into a single reaction mixture and
generate a high performance library from
hundreds or even thousands of samples
quickly and easily all of this can be
done in a total time of 90 minutes from
the DNA sample itself to a sequencer
ready Library
as you'll learn about today this has a
number of applications and you're here
you're going to hear today about the
application of plasma sequencing that
our collaborators at octant have been
exploring
and so with that I'm going to turn this
over to our collaborators Henry Henry
Chan is the synthetic biology lead at
octant and Brian Jiang is the synthetic
biology research associate they're going
to tell us today about their work in
deploying Express Flex as part of the
octopus protocol which they have
developed to support High scale High
throughput plasmid sequencing
Henry and Brian it's all yours
awesome thanks Joe uh yeah so we're
really excited to be talking to you guys
today
um about this joint collaboration
between us and SQL
um real quick I want to I'm going to
give a quick introduction on Octon we
are a
platform we are building a platform to
navigate the complexity of biology and
chemistry develop the next generation of
small molecules um so we're a
Therapeutics company but more
specifically today I want to talk a
little bit about our efforts with SQL to
help us develop and improve octopus this
is a high throughput contract sequencing
platform that we've used that really
helps enable our drug Discovery efforts
um and we're excited to share with you
all today on how sql's Express Plex kits
has enabled the possibility for the next
day turnaround a full plasmid sequence
certification I'm using octon's octopus
V3 platform that we'll talk later about
we shaped this upcoming octopus update
so that any interested labor party can
implement this within their own
workflows
Henry is going to give some context for
how onboarding Express Plex onto octopus
has enhanced our company's synthetic
biology workflow and overall
thanks Ryan
so really quick
um yeah so our fundamental we are drug
Discovery company our fundamental
hypothesis is that the current state of
drug Discovery is poorly matched uh to
address the multi-factorial nature of
human disease
um we think that next Generation
therapies are possible through
understanding the right biological
mechanisms that Target the right
receptors the right Pathways and and the
right mutations right disease is
complicated
um we don't believe that they're you
know we don't believe in the Silver
Bullet hypothesis
um let me what do I mean by this so let
me give you an example
um so autosomal dominant retinitis
Pigmentosa is a disease that leads to
Progressive blindness it is caused often
caused by misfolding mutations in the
rhodopsin gene
this leads to death of retinal cells and
the mechanism behind housings is if you
look over on the figure on the in the
middle
misfolding mutations of the rogopsin
protein will lead to
mist trafficking of the protein from ER
where it is created to the plasma
membrane
uh
chaperone small molecule chaperones
could be potential therapeutic for this
and so you could imagine a molecule that
might bind to the misfolded rhodopsin
protein and then help it adopt a more
native and wild type
confirmation this adoption of the
confirmation will rescue the trafficking
and then prevent the self-death
and so you might think one way to find
molecules that could have the
chaperoning activities you might purify
wild-type rhodopsin and then look for
small molecule binders or stabilizers of
the wild type protein and and you might
that that is certainly a fair way to
address this problem
to look for to screen for interesting
compounds with therapeutic effect
but we believe that if you take an
approach like this you're definitely
leaving a lot of potential mechanism on
the table
and so when you
you know in the process of you know in
the in the cell right uh a misfolded
rhodopsin protein might will have will
undergo all these different processes
will experience all these different
processes right like biogenesis
translation from the ribosome
um trafficking from the ER to the Golgi
uh to the cell membrane the molecule
will have many a potential therapeutic
or chaperone will have many
opportunities to interact on all of
those uh complex
stages of trafficking and folding
additionally uh there are there's not
just one single kind of mutation right
that leads to adrp there are actually
hundreds of known mutations and so a
truly Best in Class therapeutic might
you might for truly Best in Class
they're predict you might want to
address many of most many or most of
these mutations and uh you don't want to
leave any mechanism on the table by only
screening for binding to Wild type
person you want to look for things that
affect the biogenesis and trafficking at
the cellular level
and so this is one of our fundamental
hypotheses right um and and around it is
around this hypothesis that we've built
our drug Discovery platform which we're
calling the Navigator
um
to that end we have two kind of uh
platforms uh the biology platform where
we utilize Multiplex cellular assays to
do our to help us optimize drugs and to
do more precise drug design uh to
multi-factorial mechanisms and mutations
and then the other side of this the
other part of our platform which I won't
talk about today is our high duplicate
chemistry platform which allows us to
design and iterate and generate tens of
thousands of molecules every week
and this you know rapid iteration allows
us to really quickly optimize
our drug designs more rapidly
and so
um we refer a bit to what we refer to
our biology side as cellular
intelligence and this is based a lot on
technology that our Founders srika Suri
um
has pioneered so so sri's uh SRI did a
lot of research as a professor in some
technology and genomic Technologies
really pioneered Multiplex um essays and
and these and these types of
Technologies like synthesis Gene editing
um
and so a lot of our biology platform is
built around our ability to engineer
human cell lines with genetic barcodes
these bar codes report on are able to
report on the activity of different
targets in Multiplex and when we build
these Multiplex barcode assays we use
these as
uh screens and assays for
identifying and optimizing interesting
therapeutic compounds
and so the two main ways in which our
multiplexing technology
breaks out are in the broad target scan
and in the Deep mutational scan BTS or
DMs
so in the BTS we can screen we can
screen a hundred different targets or
100 different mutations of the same
Target or a mixture mixture of both
right
um
in 384 while format and at this scale we
can do tens of thousands of molecules
against 100 different targets or
variants or mutations
the other side of this is the mutational
scan here we can
we can
um
tens of thousands of mutations in
parallel so you can imagine we can make
every single amino acid mutation
to a given protein and then map out all
of that at once
um you know in a big dish and so this
allowed this could get us to uh you know
understanding some SAR or structure
activity functional relationships
um
at a very granular level whereas on the
BTS gets us you know these broad
chemical screens at many targets more
broadly
how did this play out for
um adrp so we built a multiplex
trafficking assay and
um you know as I told you before
rhodopsin has hundreds of known
mutations and that cause retinitis
Pigmentosa we were able to build many of
these and then Multiplex them into a
single high throughput screenable assay
and then from that we were able to find
compounds that actually rescue 80 of the
traffic and mutations that we tested so
in this plot on the bottom right
um You can see we've we've identified
three compounds
um about half this level of rescue each
square is actually a dose response curve
and because we're multiplexing the
density of data that we get is actually
quite high so in a 384 role play we're
getting like you know hundreds of those
response you know equivalence of dose
response curves that you might collect
on say like a luciferase or fluorescence
assay
um but this is against uh many variants
at the same time
building these assays however requires
uh building and building these assets
requires a lot of work
tons of cloning optimization were
involved and so in building the assay
that we just talked about
um
we optimize at least 14 different
synthetic components
um to be able to achieve uh signal that
we were satisfied with
and in this process we tested at least
400 contracts
that you know is that is not the end or
the only Multiplex trafficking assay
that we that we want to build there are
many different mechanisms that we want
to pursue
um there's an example it's not just some
example of the ones on the left that we
can build in cell assays and then um
there's also the the reporter element
that expresses the barcode and so we've
also found a lot of things uh to
optimize both on the mechanism side and
the promoter side that actually
expresses the barcode and so in in going
after building these Multiplex assays we
actually go through quite a lot of
iterations of designs and cloning and
cell engineering
and so rather quickly we had to get
really really good at cloning and so we
adopted you know a lot of the latest
Gene synthesis we take full advantage of
a lot of the latest Gene synthesis
Technologies and the pooled cloning
approaches
um
but what we really ran into really
quickly was that something is wrote as
plasmid sequencing sequence verification
and what's that by Sanger became a huge
bottleneck we were sending in thousands
of
plasmid traces obeak to you know pretty
large cro incubated at we were
incubating out of UCLA so
um I won't I won't name who the cro was
um but we're you know we were spending
quite a bit of money on them
and um they were throttling us at 90 you
know at one two to four 96 volt plates a
day uh this meant that we were getting
we were getting we were having to wait a
week to
to get our data back
um not to mention
um the cost and then also just
submitting you know tons of primers and
analyzing thousands of traces um this
this was not fun at all
and so we asked ourselves the question
you know we're we're an NGS company
um
uh Next Generation sequencing company
we live in the age of NGS why are we
being bottlenecked by decades-old
technology
um for DNA sequencing
and so the reality is that this is a
solved problem
um if your name if the name of your
company is ginkgo or avarice and you you
know you've built your company around
DNA's around like this sort of synthetic
biology we were a startup um we had two
biologists that were doing all of this
cloning
we can we obviously couldn't afford to
like build this world-class setup that
they had and this is you know back in
2019 this is when we developed octopus
um
this is a cheap and scalable height to
put full plasma sequencing
um platform that uh is super scalable is
direct from colonies so no many preps
required
um it's accessible no fancy equipment
you only need a my seek and maybe some
multi-ball pipettors
fast turnaround is comparable to Sanger
automated analysis report you don't have
to sit in front and stare at traces it
just spits out an Excel file
um it's cheap cost to say about a singer
and like
any good automation
um and process it changed the way that
we approached experimentation things
that we were able to do
um
like on the bench side in in the
molecular modular lab it just
um we were able to just take riskier
riskier um cloning approaches and go
crazy with what we wanted because we had
this this thing on the back end that
will just tell us what we were doing at
a high scale
um and then the other thing that we
thought was we should open source this
and so you could actually find
um our protocols for exactly how to do
this on GitHub we wrote a blog post
about it that's written down on the
bottom
um and so in a nutshell really quick uh
how this process works on day one you
pick colonies day two
um getting really early in the morning
you lysols you extract the DNA
um in bulk at the plate level then you
do the library prep at the time we're
using the igenomics riptide kit for
Library prep
now takes about six hours and then um
by that evening you could uh load your
my seek or your next chance sequencer
and then buy then around
um you know less than 48 hours later
um you get your results your analyze
pipeline results
and so as you can see on the plot over
on the top right in the first six months
that we developed this
we loved it we used we basically
sequenced 12 000 plasmids on this using
octopus and again as I told you we only
had like two molecular biologists and we
had one ra that was running this
um but you know there were still some
things that were not perfect about it
and I'll I'll pass it off to Brian to
tell you about it yeah
thanks Henry
um now I wasn't around the time
um to run the one of octopus but from
when I let it but from what I understand
running day two sample prep and Library
prep by hand was quite a pain in the
butt and also the cell lysine method
being used resulted in higher gdna bias
than we would have liked
um so reducing the Hands-On labor
required in the gdna bias culminated in
the V2 update of octopus
um one major change was the onboarding
of uh rolling Circle amplification to
replace the older cell lysis sample prep
method that we had
um modifying um RCA with the addition of
plasmid specific primers greatly
improved the quality of our sequencing
by reducing the amount of G DNA
contamination
additionally we utilized the open trons
ot2 liquid handling robot this robot was
um was uh is cheap automation
um that's really further reduced the
amount of Hands-On
um kind of uh yeah laborious work
required to get through the day two
Library prep
um but while we addressed the gdna and
Hands-On labor problems with the V2
update
um the library process itself
um still um while still using the um
Library kit that we had
um still had a lot of moving parts that
made the process more complicated than
we would have liked
yeah and so then this is this is
actually
um around last year this is when we got
in contact with uh the folks over at
sequel um Roger and Joe they they found
us through our blog posts and and they
reached out to us and they said hey we
have this kit
um called expressplex we think you might
be interested in and we they showed us
this protocol
you know doesn't get simpler than that
and takes 90 minutes
um Compares that to the riptide protocol
which which um if you guys know Riptide
was bought out by by twist
um it's now called twist 96 Plex but we
refer to as Riptide because
we actually never bought any kits from
twist we had so many other Riptide kits
um
but anyway uh just compare that to the
to the riptide protocol super long takes
like about five to six hours many steps
many ways that you you can mess this up
um there was always training involved
and so we saw this protocol
um the express Flex protocol and we were
like yes we would love we would love to
be the alpha testers for for this
product
um and so we brought it on and in the in
a our early prototyping our kind of
early testing was we found out that
the sequencing bias between Riptide and
expressplex was basically the same
um
in terms of performance if not maybe
Express Flex even has a slight Edge on
it when I'm showing you here
um it's just like kind of biased plots
from two random plasmids that we've done
we've done more kind of more rigorous
statistical analysis on the back end to
convince ourselves but I think the
takeaway is you know to date we've we've
sequenced now 65 000 plasmas using the
riptide Library kit prep kit never
experienced any issues
um obviously bias is going to be
introduced whenever you have Library
prep
um
and so but you know it was fine for us
and so when we saw something that was
almost just was basically just as good
if not better we were super happy with
that and um as of you know today we
sequenced around seven to ten thousand
thousands using expressplex Library prep
kit and again no issues there
and so with that we were really excited
uh actually Brian was really excited uh
to bring expressplex on board yeah
um yeah yeah basically yeah with the
simplified and like faster Library prep
that Express Plex
um like allowed
um it made my life a lot easier and uh
running octopus and it shortened the
library prep day quite a lot
um
yeah and
um but this also got us thinking that if
we were able to make the library prep
day this much shorter and able to turn
RCA
um that was formerly uh overnight
process and squeeze it into the same day
as the library prep we might be able to
get next day turnaround of um our plasma
sequencing and indeed um we'll uh talk
about this later but
um yeah this culminated yeah with our
upcoming V3 updates of octopus by
combining the speed of um and simplicity
of the express Plex
um Library prep with a shorter RCA
protocol we were able to achieve next
day turnaround
um of uh a full plasmid sequence
verified sequences and additionally
um and additionally uh the library
library prep process is um it can be
assisted by the region
yeah I mean this is this is crazy right
like it's literally faster than Sanger
um and as Brian mentioned we're going to
be releasing these protocols soon
um just being the watch out for that we
haven't actually written everything up
um yes
but it works it's it's awesome
and so this again like this this changes
everything for us
um
basically taking a two-day process to
one day
um this dramatically shortens times of
data right and so in our workflows you
can imagine
um if you order say you're super excited
from you know coming in on from thinking
about your problem on the weekend you
come in on Monday fired up you're
ordering primers you clone them you know
if you and then IDT delivers them on
Tuesday because they're amazing
and then you clone on Tuesday and then
you do octopus on Wednesday you get your
results by Thursday uh and you can then
now set up your experiment
um or if you mess up reorder primers on
Thursday and if you set up your
experiment on Thursday then you can you
know for us we transcribed on Friday
that allows you to take advantage of the
weekend incubation or reclone on Friday
and so because of like the weekend right
and the way that you know the week
breaks out and lab work just happens
this one day shortening of the processes
gives us two turns of the crank on any
given experiment rather than one this is
huge right
the other side of this too is this this
easier workflow until now everybody has
had to rely on Brian to run octopus for
them because of this super long and
involved Library prep you know only
Brian knows how to make the ot2 seem
like it does
um but now it's just you know one step
transfer and then put it onto the
library we can actually democratize this
with an opt-in and people can run it
um our vision is that anybody who does
molecular biology can just run octopus
whenever they need to and not have to
wait for Brian
um the other side of this too is
you know a lot of people reach out to us
um about octopus and I know at least at
least
um you know 10 companies that are
probably using octopus right now
and I would imagine many more would use
it if they knew it was this easy and was
literally faster than Sanger
um
and so we also Imagine right
there are more turns of the crank
um but also more turns of the crank
democratized out to everyone within
Ogden but also outside of Ogden to
um in which we're really excited to be
able to share this protocol
and so in summary
um Octon is building the next we are a
drug Discovery company
um we're building the next we're trying
to build the next generation of small
molecule Therapeutics by leveraging
synthetic biology and Multiplex
cell-based assays and our
hyperbochemistry platform
uh octopus has been this tool that we've
developed has been greatly enabling
um for the synthetic biology efforts
here in the engineering of cell based
assays and with this collaboration and
the Advent and Advent of expressplex
into the workflow
uh this reduction in turnaround time
labor and expertise for octopuses
greatly increase the usefulness and
accessibility of this yeah and as
fastest you can have
um that with the octopus input you can
have transformed uh colonies on day one
too many practical verified Culture by
the next day
um our platform will be freely available
for open source collaboration and which
will benefit across all Labs as well as
an og2 protocol to further simplify them
yeah and with that I'd like to just
um you know some shout outs here uh Nate
Nathan lubach he was the he was a
scientist a bioinformatician at the time
um he helped write he wrote most of the
analysis pipeline for octopus Johnny was
that first R.A we talked about made a
lot of improvements for the U1 and D2
Liz uh was a second ra Runner she made
some improvements
um to the what work will kind of spruced
up the uh the analysis pipeline for us a
little bit and then Brian has done a lot
of improvements to V2 and V3 and is the
current runner for us right now
um for the rhodopson project Eric Jones
is the lead scientist
and then our two Founders are uh Shri
kosuri and Ramsay hamsani and then the
folks over at sequel Joe Roger Curtis
Jack Kelly Samantha you guys have all
been great and super helpful
um in this collaboration and we're
excited to continue working with them
um and so with that I'll thank you guys
for your attention and
um
give the Florida any questions
well thank you Joe Henry and Brian for
your informative presentation we will
now start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and we'll answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for all right so let's get started
our first question asks are the
protocols for octopus and express Plex
published or available to review
um Joe I don't I think
I think uh the express Flex Protocols
are literally like
what you see in the slides I don't know
if you have more than that but um in
terms of octopus we are currently trying
to write up the protocols and formalize
them we hope to we hope to have that
finished by the end of March
um
to get a sense for like what the
workflow is for octopus
um buying it you know Sans the been like
Fast RCA and the express Plex you can
take a look at our
um our GitHub and our blog posts
um there'll be a much longer version of
the protocol there but you um yeah just
stay tuned we're we're trying to write
them up as we speak
yeah just to add to that on the
expressplex information certainly
anybody who's interested in learning
more can reach out to any any us at SQL
this product will be officially launched
uh uh next month and so we're certainly
looking forward to publishing a lot more
information on protocols and Etc on our
website soon
great thank you another question we have
here how much time did it take you to
integrate Express Plex into your overall
workflow
um uh yeah so the expressplex kit it
came it's as simplified
um it's as simple as um it can really be
just a stamping and a single uh
thermocycling reaction for us we were
able to implement Express Plex within
octopus on the first attempt in the
first run we were able to get um
uh sequence verified results
um the kit does its job right it
converts plasmid input and into a
Illumina sequencable library and the
octopus process
um basically yeah that's just what it
requires it's just a faster uh more
simplified version of the system we had
before
right next question here what is the
maximum number of samples a small
plasmids say 10 KB that can be
multiplexed within a single flow cell
um I can take that one
um so I think it depends on the
sequencing kit you use
we routinely use the
um V2 micro from the my seek from
Illumina and so I think that gets you
um four million paired in
um 150 reads and so very very
comfortably that is 8.96 well plates
um I'm pretty sure you could push that
up to twice that at the 10kb size
um but I think the limit there for us is
actually the number of unique indexes
great thank you
next question is a two-part question
here and this question asks in your
experience how long does it take to
prepare the sample normalization to
start with the protocol and the second
part of the question says can you please
briefly explain how you use RCA
yeah so I think I'll take the first part
just to maybe address the normalization
question so I think one of the really
attractive features of expressplex is it
does normalize uh over a a pretty wide
range of input DNA amount so again in I
think a typical use case
um it certainly could be a global
dilution not necessarily a individual
normalization of samples
I think you know maybe again Brian and
Henry can speak a little bit to how the
output of the RCA process kind of fits
with with that concept uh briefly
yeah so the cool thing about the RCA
process is um
when RC has run to saturation that also
is a step of normalization of all the
input samples so on top of that it
requires no um it doesn't require
um like spot quanting at the beginning
um after
you have your sample and RC has run to
saturation you can dilute that by a
global factor as you can expect all
Wells to have roughly the same amount of
input and then that can be
um stamped into the express plus kit
right
we've got another we have another
question here can express Plex be used
for applications other than plasmid
sequencing
yeah so the answer is absolutely yes
um and I think you know certainly
initially our Focus applications will be
in a wide variety of synthetic
constructs including things like
amplicons uh you know there's a sort of
key applications we see this being a
great fit for now
and we will certainly look forward to
expanding beyond that I can tell you you
know certainly we've had some really
positive data on other diverse
applications such as rna-seq that we're
looking forward to telling the world
about more uh quite soon so again I
think the answer here is you know we're
it's a new product and we're excited to
get it out there and certainly learn
from our customers about where it can go
but I think initially certainly
applications like the one you see here
today are going to be the ones that this
is really well suited for
all right thank you Joe our next
question here asks how many samples are
you processing at one time or sequencing
in a batch and how many reads are
required per sample
um
ye so with by just uh yeah so with the
Illumina micro kit
um we and uh sequencing um 150 base pair
um uh paired end
um we can we comfortably sequence with
just eight indexes um eight times 96
samples around 800 samples comfortably
getting
um an average of around 5000
um reads uh per sample that's plenty of
coverage for a 10 KB plasmid input
um and
um with more index uh indexes it's
possible to imagine running maybe up to
um 100 samples or 12 indices them
multiplied by 96 samples within a micro
kit um the octopus platform uh the
analysis pipeline is able to accommodate
um low
uh you uh that those levels um of read
coverage because
um it doesn't uh rely entirely on De
novo
um sequencing which would require a lot
of reads um but it has an intermediate
step allowing yeah basically allowing um
for uh yeah a full plasma sequencing um
upon
um yeah upon uh what what the low input
um sequencing kit yeah and then I think
um you know one day
you know if if if there is a need to do
more than
um 896 old plates per run
um
I think one that's solely possible with
the micro kit to
you know
the V3 kits are like 30 million reads so
you can imagine like 10 times the number
of samples like if you are you know one
of these like big cores or you wanna
if you're if you want to eat you know
eat the lunch of these Sanger companies
and try to conglomerate like you know
the entire countries worth of like
plasma sequencing in you know all in all
in a single location you'd probably do
that too um I think again you just
bottleneck by the by the number of
unique indexes yeah and alternatively if
um like those are like pretty large
scales
um you can also easily imagine that um
using a nano kit you know would be
sufficient with um like just like one or
two
um 96 well plates with the samples
um that would probably also give you you
know 5 000 ish reads per sample and
that's like plenty of coverage for 10kb
plasmin
well Henry and Brian I have another
question coming your way and this is
another two-part question here this
question asks do you see this technology
and approach replacing singer sequencing
at workflow and costs that Labs can
change especially Core Labs and high
volume Sanger cros service providers and
the second part says what would you pass
on as words of wisdom from your
experience to folks thinking about this
change
um
you know I think hard like doing like a
complete 100 replacement of Sanger is
probably not like what this would do I
would but I at the same time
um probably close like the vast vast
majority of plasma sequencing I don't I
don't understand why is it like I don't
see why that wouldn't be the case
um we still maintain a we still have a
account you know over over at rcro
um but I would say like 95 of the
plasmids or more even
um that we generate here at Ogden are
sequenced
um by octopus and
um especially with the easier it
workflow and the shorter turnaround time
um that is actually faster than than
what Sanger can actually provide like
there's no reason why you know for most
things the octopus can handle
um you wouldn't do this
um
like I think as in the question you know
if you don't have high volume like I
think it it stops to become kind of it's
it's not as worth it at the sub 96 well
level I think like right around there
it's still it's really worth it to do
um but if you if you are a high volume
lab or you're like a core facility at a
university or something like that
um I don't it it just doesn't make sense
to me that you would ever use Sanger
um
I think there are some things that
um like one we're not selling octopus so
like we're not we're not we are we try
to develop it to the point that's useful
to us and we share it with the world
um
but
um you know there's probably some tweaks
of the analysis pipeline that might make
some things a little bit tighter um and
then the other thing is of course like
with any kind of sequencing Library prep
there will be bias and we and like
um
if you have highly highly repetitive
sequences littered throughout your your
plasmid which
um there are all sorts of problems with
that just from the cloning and the
design side
um anyway like I think I think
I think we've seen that octopus can
choke on that a little bit
um
it you know we we can still sequence it
but it does it's not perfect
um so every now and then we'll just like
use Sanger to like spot check some
things that that seem kind of crazy
um
and then in terms of like words of
wisdom
um I think
just you I you know email us
um I like honestly I would have if it
wasn't
if it wasn't
um
this easy like if it was still V2 or V1
I would have a lot more things to say
um but
but when we when we spin up the
protocols
um you know definitely email us to
to see what might help
um and
yeah I don't know it it it's so easy
like I don't I don't I don't see any I
don't anticipate any wisdom needing to
be shared other than having having to
have this scale Brian I don't know yeah
pretty much um yeah once you're
approaching a scale of you know 96
samples or more that need to be fully
sequenced or it doesn't have to be fully
sequenced even like it's because of how
easy it is if you're on the 90s like at
that point you know analyzing Sanger
traces like becomes like the pain
um and yeah and having Octopus as an
option even as like a first pass option
right you pretty much get everything you
need and if you're still like more
comfortable with saying or you can
easily singer but over time you're like
you'll uh you'll well at least like you
know for us like we quickly realized you
know the octopus is um like pretty
sufficient for almost like all use cases
um especially especially for cases where
you have you know complex like uh
plasmids like you know uh cloned in you
know like de novo or um
um yeah or just having a lot of samples
um uh the and because all the input
samples don't have to be mini prep you
literally start from bacterial colonies
um that like further simplifies the
process you don't have to like consider
like oh I have to mini prep you know
like eights like you know maybe like
this particular uh construct you just
like pick your colonies put it in and
then just mini prep the single um you
know like perfect
um at the end
um
so that's just another benefit
um to the octopus process when you're
approaching the 96 well scale
well it looks like we have time for one
more question here so we're going to
wrap up with this one and this question
asks are you looking at any of the new
NGS platforms
yeah so I think uh you know short answer
there is you know I think
certainly from our point of view you
know multiplexing is a key need that
spans you know various sequencing
platforms uh certainly uh as as newer
platforms have have come out especially
in the last year
um I think we've seen that now become
more and more apparent
um yeah at SQL we've done I think some
really good work that I'm happy to
direct you to our website and check out
um we've we've shown uh really good
performance with our some of our other
kids with the element platform the avidi
sequencer but certainly uh looking
across you know the the Spectrum at
other platforms I think there's some
really exciting stuff going on certainly
in the long read Arena some of the new
Platforms in that space I think offer
throughput and cost it now really is
going to motivate a high level
multiplexing as well so yeah we're very
excited to to
start to Think Through how to implement
some of these Technologies on other
sequencing platforms as
um you know as they get out there
um but yeah more more to come and then
certainly uh I I certainly invite you to
take a look at again some of the work
we've already put on our website uh uh
in that regard
awesome well thank you again Joe Henry
and Brian for your time today and your
important research we would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor SQL for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speakers via
the contact information you provided at
the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
Roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time take care everyone
goodbye